the number one thing that republicans
well the democrats should be hoping for
in 2024 is that trump runs
because the only way the democrats can
still win in 2024 is if it's trump you
might be saying what the hell are you
talking about right now
because if a desantis runs or someone
with
mass appeal it's a cakewalk
but if trump gets back in there and
starts mudslinging again
i don't think
the people on the right fully understand
you might have a good grasp of this
just how much even if it's against their
own pocketbook and against their own
interests
how nails on a chalkboard he is to their
ears again it might be counterintuitive
while he was better for us
trump gets on screen gets on tv and
democrats have a meltdown i'm willing to
bet that at one point you had trump
derangement syndrome did you not i did
yeah okay
and half of america did pretty bad
though i mean we had two let me know
yeah i went to rehab
luckily they were very gorgeous women
and things are okay now i'm a little
more reasonable
but you fully understand just how much
people on the left
really
really
can't stomach trump it's a guttural
nails on a chalkboard when he gets
america and people just like i like
you understand fully
so for me
i'm telling
putting this out there i've never voted
for a republican for president in my
life i will gladly take a ron desantis
or someone who has those um conservative
agendas just because i think democrat i
had a conversation with a very high up
democratic uh
fundraiser here in on the dnc side one
of my best friends i was like you
understand how
[ __ ] up the democrats are doing these
days he's like yeah i'm totally with you
and i said the democrats are praying
that trump is the is the
candidate in 2024 stop 100 stop because
the sentence does santa you really
believe that [ __ ] ten thousand
percent you really believe that yeah oh
really okay so let me ask you because
you can stomach trump so you don't
understand what i'm saying because i can
set aside my emotions and you're one of
two percent of the people that can do
that don't need everybody and more of
america needs to learn to be like her
and sit down and have she had trump
derangement syndrome but she's getting
over it
but how many other people have gotten
over it but no no but by the way a lot
of people have gone over it a lot of
people have gone over yeah but you
selective hearing want to believe that
let me explain to you something for you
to be thinking about okay
let's let's take your argument of
they want uh trump to run oh really yeah
if they really wanted trump to run you
wouldn't see [ __ ] with january 6 hearing
zero if they really wanted trump to run
you wouldn't see an article coming out
saying iran is trying to assassinate
president trump oh my god because the
democrats want him to run if democrats
wanted trump to run they would sit down
nancy pelosi's with guys enough would
generate let this guy run he's going to
lose let this guy run he's going to lose
do you see republicans worried about
hillary clinton running republicans are
hoping hillary clinton running they're
not even getting in or wait have you
heard republicans talking [ __ ] about
hillary because they're hoping that's
how you know anytime they go after
somebody they're afraid that guy's gonna
run and you're smart enough and wise
enough to know the difference but
selective hearing no gets you to say
well now because the democrats are
hoping he runs no i'm not you're you're
taking half of my argument no no no you
have to know better than that saying do
they want trump yeah hell no do they are
they rooting for trump hell no but
they're saying they're looking at the
field they're saying
if biden is is the guy which i don't
think he will be
who do we have a better chance against
young
uh vibrant rhonda santa has to be wiser
than that strategically
you just made you don't think that john
desantis has a better chance of beating
a democrat than trump i think ron
burgundy has a better chance of beating
anybody on the left right now it doesn't
matter who it is the point i'm trying to
make to you is just think about the
logic of what you're saying right now
okay you know the saying is santo says
if an enemy is falling don't get in his
way get out of his way let him fall okay
that's strategic no problem
if they're really afraid of trump fallen
why do they keep getting in his way
they're afraid
they're afraid of this guy whether it's
true or not it's here i don't think
trump's a strategy going after musk and
doing all the i don't i don't
you know you heard what i said on the
guy you know a couple people on twitter
came after me saying what happened to
you you had our back and you were trump
i said i've never been a trump an
anti-trump a pro-this i've been a
economy guy with policies that allows us
to be left alone and the same people
that were so ecstatic about this guy was
going to become a president to unify
america is the reason why we're
experiencing what we're experiencing
right now so i understand the idea of
protecting your vote because it sucks
when you lose i understand it to have to
protect that i still made the right
decision because i would have never
voted i get it the ego is a hard thing
we all have it totally understand that
but the premise behind the fact that oh
dude democrats are hoping for
and i want to get your opinion here we
go respect
i'm not saying i don't think you
understand
i generally don't
how disgusted i understand strategy no
no no no hear me out
how disgusted half of america feels when
they see him speak
i don't think you fully get i run an
insurance company with 27 000 agents in
49 states who talk to these people every
day i don't think you understand that
i'm around these guys constantly from
every state and you're only in florida
i'm in every state okay i'm not but what
i'm trying to tell you is i hear their
last week we're doing something at the
office and i said hillary clinton is a
sweetheart one of the ladies says she is
a sweetheart
i'm in the street talking i know i'm the
i have to be there i have to win the
guy's vote or else you don't got you
don't have a business
that you're growing
america's bigger than new york city
america's bigger than miami okay america
is america you got 50 states you're
dealing with and a lot of them
it doesn't need to be a hundred percent
of them it just needs to be five to ten
percent of them disagree with you ten
thousand people in the midwest that's
who controls our country that's the
point yeah and they're sick of it not
not adam by the way
you whether you're gonna work i don't
know
do do what you got to do a lot of people
are very protective of who they voted
because they hate being wrong i'm not
it's zero percent about me i'm talking
about 50 percent of the country that
when trump speaks yeah it's nails on a
chalkboard to them who gives a [ __ ]
because because when joe biden speaks
it's freaking awesome no they go to
school because when he speaks they go to
sleep
i want to get up and go yeah you've had
trouble arrangement since so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]